Dakota has Kathy Lee Jenna or any of
your co-hosts ever shared a story about
you on air without your prior knowledge
that you really wish they hadn't
um sounds familiar I feel like I kind of
turned the tables on Jenna cap did it to
me she she threw one huge uh grenade
once yeah Hoda kotb's still kinda
scarred from a story Kathy Lee Gifford
spilled while they were live on air this
is a hardly earth-shattering news by any
means breaking news Kathy Lee knows what
it's not that on Watch What Happens live
with Andy Cohen Hoda was asked if any of
her co-hosts have ever said anything
about her on live TV that she wishes
they hadn't the answer yes with Kathy
Hoda's previous co-host on the Today
Show's fourth hour it all started when
Hoda shared this personal story prior to
going on air I was telling her that I
was married uh once before and I met my
husband on thing on Valentine's Day and
we I got the divorce papers on
Valentine's Day and it was Valentine's
Day and I said she goes oh it's
Valentine's Day I go I hate Valentine's
Day we're in the makeup room she goes
why and I told her that story I go ugh
anyway I hate it and when it came time
to go on TV Kathy threw Hoda what she
calls a grenade
so anyway we go out to the set and it's
all decorated with flowers and hearts
and I go good morning Happy Valentine's
Day and she looks to me and she goes not
for you I go nothing I go what are you
doing but I remember that grenade fell
right on the table and I didn't know
what to do and I go and I was so new I
didn't know what to say and I said to
her like that was makeup room talk that
wasn't like for out here because we're
happy out here so yeah an awkward moment
that stayed with Hoda but still the
ladies also share plenty of good times
when is it over why isn't it over
[Music]
[Music]
um every single day with kath is fun
even on her bad days they're good days
for me and
um we have a thing where I think every
now and then in life you meet someone
and it clicks just like two puzzle
pieces and we found each other and that
some people go their whole life and
don't find it yeah I mean how lucky are
we late in life to find it but all the
on-air fun came to an end in 2019 when
Kathy decided to step away from the
morning show if you just want to like
remind people of why this show worked in
the beginning because we have fun and we
we have a friendship and it's real I
mean I didn't even know Hoda when I
started uh working with her I had one
one lunch you would have never known
because you gals just seem like the
fastest of friends and yeah this girl
couple that every like that's what you
want you and your girlfriends to be we
came we were colleagues at first of
course and through it took about a year
it took about a year and then no she was
she's one account for her among my
dearest friends but even after Kathy's
exit her friendship with Hoda remains as
strong as ever we really let each other
be ourselves authentic in each in each
other's company she never put a burden
on me of any kind at all that's why I
stayed so long
[Music]